In the celestial court of the Jade Emperor
lived seven princesses.
Each had their chosen place in court,
but the youngest princess
had a special skill.
She could pluck clouds from the sky
and spin them into the softest robes.
Her work was so precise,
not even the most expert eye
could find a seam.
But her craft was the same day after day,
and she longed for new inspiration.
Finally, the Queen Mother granted
the weaver permission to visit Earth.
The other princesses would accompany her
to protect their sister
from earthly dangers.
Dressed in special robes that allowed them
to fly between Heaven and Earth,
the sisters soared down from the sky.
The weaver was in awe
of the rolling hills and rivers,
and the sisters decided to swim
in one of the glittering streams.
As the weaver floated,
she dreamt about staying forever.
Meanwhile, a lone cowherd
approached the riverbank.
He came here often
to sweep his parent’s grave
and speak with his only companion—
a stoic bull who listened patiently
to the cowherd’s sorrows.
But upon seeing the weaver’s beauty,
the cowherd forgot his routine.
While he longed to introduce himself,
his lonely lifestyle had made him timid.
Thankfully, the bull saw his friend's
plight and offered some advice.
He told the cowherd of the swimmer’s
celestial origins
and of her dream to stay on Earth;
but also that she could only remain
if she lost her ticket back to Heaven.
As the cowherd approached,
the princesses flew away in fear—
leaving their dreaming sister behind.
While keeping her magic robes hidden,
the cowherd offered his own garment
as a substitute.
And after gaining her trust,
the pair began exploring the countryside.
She was struck by his caring nature,
and he learned to see
the world’s wonder through her eyes.
Before long, the two had
fallen deeply in love.
The weaver and the cowherd
built a prosperous life.
Their farm flourished, and the weaver
taught her skills to local villagers.
As time marched on, the pair was
blessed with two healthy children,
but their bull was growing old.
Before he died, the bull implored
the family to keep his hide
and use its magic at their time of need.
While the husband grieved for his friend,
the weaver’s mind turned
to her other family.
Dusting off her magical robe,
she decided to pay a visit to the heavens.
But when the weaver
swept into her old home,
no one seemed surprised to see her.
With a start, she realized
that barely any time had passed—
for a year on Earth
was merely a day in Heaven.
When her family learned of her new life,
they were enraged.
How dare she waste her love on a human?
The weaver tried to escape back to Earth,
but the Queen Mother plucked
a golden hairpin from her head
and tore through the sky.
A great gulf opened, forming a river
of stars between Heaven and Earth.
Below, the cowherd trembled, but he also
remembered the bull’s final words.
Hastily placing each child in a basket,
he draped the bull’s pelt
over his back and hurtled upwards.
Above the clouds, each lover attempted
to wade through the surging stars.
But no matter how hard they struggled,
the gulf between them
only grew wider.
Day after day, the Queen Mother
watched without pity.
Years passed, and the weaver
and the cowherd had no one,
except the passing magpies
to cheer them on.
Finally, their love moved
the Queen Mother’s heart.
While she couldn’t forgive
her granddaughter entirely,
the Queen Mother would allow the weaver
to meet her earthly family once a year.
And so, in late summer, the magpies
form a bridge across the Milky Way,
reuniting the weaver and the cowherd.
At this time of year, millions of people
in East and Southeast Asian countries
tell similar tales of these
star-crossed lovers,
celebrating their annual reunion.